I want to tell you this story about the
time I almost got kidnapped in the trunk
of a red Mazda Miata it's a day after
graduating from Design School and I'm
having a yard sale and this guy pulls up
in this red Mazda and he starts looking
through my stuff and he buys a piece of
art that I made and it turns out he's
alone in town for the night driving
cross-country on a road trip before he
goes into the Peace Corps so I invite
him out for a beer and he tells me all
about his passion for making a
difference in the world now it's
starting to get late and I'm getting
pretty tired as I motion for the tab I
make the mistake of asking him so where
you staying tonight and he makes it
worse by saying actually I don't have a
place I'm thinking oh man what do you do
we've all been there right don't offer
to host this guy but I just met him I
mean he says he's going to the Peace
Corps but I don't really know he's going
to Peace Corps and I don't want to end
up kidnapped in the trunk of a Miata
that's a small trunk so then I hear
myself saying hey I've got an air bed
you can stay on in my living room and
the voice in my head goes wait what that
night I'm laying in bed I'm staring at
the ceiling I'm thinking oh my god what
have I done there's a complete stranger
sleeping in my living room
what if he's psychotic my anxiety grows
so much I leap out of bed I sneak on my
tiptoes to the door and I locked the
bedroom door it turns out he was not
psychotic we've kept in touch ever since
and the piece of art he bought at the
yard sale is hanging in his classroom
he's a teacher now
this is my first hosting experience and
it completely changed my perspective
maybe the people that my child had
taught me to label as strangers were
actually friends waiting to be
discovered the idea of hosting people on
air beds gradually became natural to me
and when I moved to San Francisco I
brought the air bed with me so now it's
two years later I'm unemployed I'm
almost broke my roommate moves out and
then the rent goes up and then I learned
there's a design conference coming to
town and all the hotels are sold out and
I've always believed that turning fear
into fun is the gift of creativity so
here's what I pitch my best friend and
my new roommate Brian Chesky Brian
thought of a way to make a few bucks
turning our place into designers Bed and
Breakfast offering designers who come to
town a place to crash complete with
wireless internet a small desk space
sleeping mat and breakfast each morning
ha we built a basic website and air bed
and breakfast was born three lucky
guests got to stay on a $20 air bed on
the hardwood floor but they loved it and
so did we
I swear the ham swiss cheese omelets we
made tasted totally different because we
made him for a guest we took him on
adventures around the city and when we
said goodbye to the last guest the door
latch clicked Brian and I just stared at
each other did we just discover it was
possible to make friends while also
making rent the wheels had started to
turn my old roommate Nate Bashar's ik
joints and Connor and we buckled down to
see if we could turn this into a
business here's what we pitched
investors we want to build a website
where people publicly post pictures of
their most intimate spaces their
bedrooms the bathrooms the kinds of
rooms you usually keep closed when
people come over and then over the
Internet they're going to invite
complete strangers to come sleep in
their homes
it's gonna be huge we sat back and we
waited for the rocket ship to blast off
it did not no one in their right minds
would invest in a service that allows
strangers asleep in people's homes why
because we've all been taught as kids
strangers equal danger now when you're
faced with a problem you fall back on
what you know and all we really need was
design in art school you learn that
design is much more than the look and
feel of something it's the whole
experience we wanted to do that for
objects but here we were aiming to build
Olympic trust between people who had
never met could design make that happen
is it possible to design for trust I
want to give you a sense of the flavor
of trust that we were aiming to achieve
I've got a 30 second experiment that
will push you past your comfort zone if
you're up for it give me a thumbs up
okay I need you to take out your phones
now that you have your phone out I'd
like you to unlock your phone now hand
your unlocked phone to the person on
your left
that tiny sense of panic you're feeling
right now is exactly how a host feel the
first time they open their home because
the only thing more personal than your
phone is your home people don't just see
your messages they see your bedroom your
kitchen your toilet now how does it feel
holding someone's unlocked phone
most of the feel really responsible
that's how most guests feel when they
stay in a home and it's because of this
that our company can even exist by the
way who's holding Al Gore's phone would
you tell Twitter he's running for
president
okay you can hand your phones back now
so now that you've experienced the kind
of trust challenge we were facing I'd
love to share a few discoveries we've
made along the way now what if we
changed one small thing about the design
of that experiment what if your neighbor
had introduced themselves first with
their their name where they're from the
name of their kids or their dog imagine
that they had 150 reviews of people
saying they're great at holding unlocked
phones
now how would you feel the hand in your
phone over it turns out a well-designed
reputation system is key for building
trust and we didn't actually get it
right the first time it's hard for
people to leave bad reviews eventually
we learn to wait until both guest and
host left the review before we reveal
them now here's a discovery we've made
just last week we did a joint study with
Stanford where we looked at people's
willingness to trust someone based on
how similar they are in age location and
geography the research showed not
surprisingly we prefer people who are
like us the more different somebody is
the less we trust them now that's a
natural social bias but what's
interesting is what happens when you add
reputation into the mix in this case
with reviews now if you've got less than
three reviews nothing changes but if
you've got more than 10 everything
changes high reputation beats high
similarity the right design can actually
help us overcome one of our most deeply
rooted biases now we also learn that
building the right amount of trust takes
the right amount of disclosure this is
what happens when a guest first messages
a host if you share too little like yo
acceptance rates go down and if you
share too much like I'm having issues
with my mother acceptance rates also go
down but there's a zone that's just
right like love the artwork in your
place coming for vacation with my family
so how do we design for just the right
amount of disclosure we use the size of
the box to suggest the right length and
we guide them with prompts to encourage
sharing we bet our whole company on the
hope that
with the right design people would be
willing to overcome the stranger-danger
bias what we didn't realize is just how
many people were ready and waiting to
put the bias aside this is a graph that
shows our rate of adoption there's three
things happening here the first an
unbelievable amount of luck the second
is the efforts of our team and the third
is the existence of a previously
unsatisfied need now things have been
going pretty well obviously there are
times when things don't work out yes
have thrown unauthorized parties and
trashed homes hosts have left guests
stranded in the rain in the early days I
was customer service and those calls
came right to my cell phone I was at the
the front lines of trust breaking and
there's nothing worse than those calls
it hurts to even think about them and
the disappointment and the sound of
someone's voice was and I would say
still is our single greatest motivator
to keep improving thankfully out of the
hundred and twenty three million nights
we've ever hosted less than a fraction
of a percent had been problematic turns
out people are justified in their trust
and when trust works out right it can be
absolutely magical we had a guest stay
with a host in Uruguay and he suffered a
heart attack the hosts rushed him to the
hospital they donated their own blood
for his operation let me read you his
review
excellent house for sedentary travelers
prone to myocardial infarctions the area
is beautiful and has direct access to
the best hospitals Xavier and Alejandra
instantly become guardian angels who
will save your life without even knowing
you they will rush you to the hospital
in their own car while you're dying and
stay in the waiting room while the
doctors give you a bypass they don't
when you feel lonely they bring you
books to read and they let you stay at
their house extra nights without
charging you highly recommended
of course not every stay is like that
but this connection beyond the
transaction is exactly what the sharing
economy is aiming for now when I heard
that term I have to admit like it
tripped me up like how do share in and
transactions go together so let's be
clear it is about commerce but if you
just called it the rental economy it
would be incomplete the sharing economy
is commerce with the promise of human
connection people share a part of
themselves and that changes everything
you know how most travel today is like I
think of it like fast food right it's
efficient and consistent right at the
cost of local and authentic what if
travel were like a magnificent buffet of
local experiences what if anywhere you
visited there was a central marketplace
of locals offering to get you thoroughly
drunk on a pub crawl in neighborhoods
you didn't even know existed or learning
to cook from a chef of a five-star
restaurant today homes are designed
around the idea of privacy and
separation what if homes were designed
to be shared from the ground up what
would that look like
what if cities embraced a culture of
sharing I see a future of shared cities
that bring us community and connection
instead of isolation in separation in
South Korea the city of Seoul it
actually even started this they've
repurposed hundreds of government
parking spots to be shared by residents
they're connecting students who need a
place to live with empty nesters who
have extra rooms and they started an
incubator to help fund the next
generation of sharing economy startups
tonight just on our service 785 thousand
people in 191 countries
we'll either stay in a stranger's home
or welcome one into theirs clearly it's
not as crazy as we were taught we didn't
invent anything new Hospitality has been
around forever there's been many other
websites like ours so why did ours
eventually take off luck and timing
aside I've learned that you can take the
components of trust and you can design
for that design can overcome our most
deeply rooted stranger-danger bias and
that's amazing to me it blows my mind I
think about this every time I see a red
Miata go by now we know design won't
solve all the world's problems but if
you can help out with this one if it can
make a dent in this it makes me wonder
what else can we design for next thank
you